dear universe  please make next year easier for all of  us please let those who have lost loved  ones find a way to say goodbye and find  comfort in the living  [Music]  please let us be thankful for what we  have and show compassion to those  without  please let the victims of hate and  ignorance find protection in those  willing to stand up for them  [Music]  please let everyone who withstood  disaster find a way to rebuild and make  it better for them  [Music]  please let those in conflict find  resolution and protect the weak and  unarmed from those who abuse power  [Music]  please let us celebrate each other's  victories and celebrate those who help  us find wonder in this world  [Music]  [Music]  and please let us continue to come  together when it really counts  [Music]  [Music]  dear universe  please make next year easier for  everyone  [Music]  you